un nuevo capítulo judicial inició este
miércoles en Guatemala para determinar
la responsabilidad de los militares en
una masacre indígena ocurrida el 29 de
julio de 1982 este caso en particular se
denomina el de rancho bejuco que es el
caserío en el departamento de Baja
Verapaz donde presuntamente un grupo de
militares acorraló a 25 indígenas dentro
de una vivienda para luego bombardearlos
y de esta forma asesinarlos ante el
tribunal de mayor riesgo de en ciudad de
Guatemala deberán comparecer los
indicados desde comandante comisionados
hasta patrulleros por la muerte de estos
indígenas entre los que se cuentan 17
menores de edad entre los 8 meses y los
13 años de edad para la época el estado
estaba comandado por el ya fallecido
dictador Efraín Ríos montt un militar
golpista que fue protagonista de estos
largos 36 años de guerra civil en
Guatemala y dado que actualmente se
denuncia desde organismos
internacionales como locales que el
aparato judicial en Guatemala está
cooptado por los intereses de personas
muy poderosas puede que este llegue a
ser un juicio enrevesado basta contener
el antecedente del 2022 del año pasado
cuando el juez Miguel Ángel Gálvez quien
envió a juicio a nueve militares por
secuestros desapariciones forzadas
asesinatos durante ese periodo de la
guerra civil tuvo que oír del país y hoy
se encuentra en el exilio